hi guys and welcome to let's play
rollercoaster three I think this is
episode 90 that was basically because I
had to I had to combine both episode 89
and 90 289 because something went wrong
with the recording as you probably have
noticed but today on the menu we have a
special dish and that is the Q now you
may or may not know about this boat and
the queue line is a very infamous thing
for me since I'm very well known to
completely suck tits when it comes to
cute absolutely terrible which is due to
a couple of reasons I mean for one I
just haven't had too much experience
with them honestly I don't even know how
cute really work in theme park so at
least I didn't really know up until I
really built this Q since I did get
quite some help in the stream because I
haven't just been in a theme park for a
couple of years and I really haven't
paid too much attention to it and then
there's also the fact that I just don't
really like you just kind of regard them
as that sort of thing at the back which
doesn't really receive all of the
scenery and I'm not really too
interested in so that's also thing and
there is of course is the fact that I
really don't have too much experience
with how I should even make them look a
tiny bit nicer I mean it works all right
foot flat rides since you don't really
have to do too much about it but for big
attractions it's definitely a different
thing but in the end the queue was built
at the end of the stream and we were all
still alive and i'm still at ok need to
do not do that and so yeah whether it's
a good or really bad q I'll leave that
up to anybody to decide but in the end I
think it kind of works out also yeah I'm
talking about the queue already even
though that's not even built yet because
I'm getting ahead of myself that was
actually at some point a comment about a
silver i think the the the video and the
audio are not completely synced for this
this video on youtube over here which is
actually always the case i always make
sure to actually sync the audio and the
video it just happens way too often that
i can ahead of myself but then again
this is just a simple station works over
here is really to interesting how it
some sort of unfinished at the moments i
still need to get rid of the station
railings and actually be able to set up
the station proper
and get some extra railings on the side
of the station right now it's not going
to be two functional then again I don't
really care too much for this station
just some simple little planters details
and lights and then I think we're all
good that being said I did I did care
about the queue over here since I do
want to have a more realistic approach
to this park that includes actually
getting the queues done right and
whatever other details I still want to
add to my attractions so yeah I did get
a lot of help over here in the stream
and I want to at the same time just kind
of apologize for all the people were
there for all my stubbornness sometimes
I just completely flat out to refuse to
do anything that was taught me which
some in some cases really resorted to me
having to in the end actually admit that
I was completely wrong but then again I
did got some great help in that stream
and it did help actually getting a
decent Q over here which I think in the
end is probably decent it might still
have some realism problems like and
still don't know exactly how in real
life these things would work but I think
we're getting there I'm not too much of
a theme park enthusiasts oh excuse me
for not knowing too much of it over here
but then again I do have plenty of
people I suppose around me that can help
me with that so that's awesome but yeah
the approach to this Q is actually very
simple I almost actually had
functionality over aesthetics over here
and the well they sort of cut out
layouts that I had for it was just the
first half is what's usually going to be
used as the cue and the second half is
what is usually going to be closed off
but just for when it gets like when that
when really many people that for some
reason want to ride my boring log flume
that I actually have the capacity to
queue up all those people as well and
yeah so I suppose it really works in a
very simple way I don't even understand
how I don't understand cues I mean
they've really are is straightforward
thing when you think about it and this Q
over here isn't really going to have too
much theming that is something that I
definitely want to work towards having
more
cuse especially for the dark rides of
course with many props and scenery
around it but that's definitely not the
case over here it's just going to be
rocks and some nice views of the roller
coasters but then again that is also a
bit of a functional reason I have
actually read some articles about queues
which had some very interesting and
points to bring up about the fact that a
queue isn't just to queue of people and
make sure that you can actually have
people enter the ride in a fair way but
it really is also all about actually
entertaining the guests while you
getting cute while you're getting the
guests queued up in that way since
you're going to be spending a lot of
your time of them being in a theme park
especially when you're in a really big
busy theme park or when you just had a
very bad day over there so you do want
to somehow somewhat entertain your
guests and you can't just BAM TVs for
that like in roller coaster Kuhn anybody
remember that the earlier roller coaster
coons just TVs freaking everywhere in
the cuse it looked like [ __ ] but your
guests were entertained somehow that was
amazing they were ugly though but that's
totally beside the point um so yeah with
basic sort of scenery that I had over
here was just basic rock work and
foliage and of course lights to make it
look a tiny bit better than just an
empty queue with nothing to it and it
does have a tiny bit of right
interaction over here though and I think
it does have some pretty good views of
the hill that BM writers write so that
are the these slight cons of the queue
in the end it's really not too special
but then again I was sort of proud at
the end and I know this might sound
really weird but thing is i have made
countless facades in my life in roller
coaster can three and i feel at this
point i could just build a brilliant
facade and still be like hmm ok now went
alright let's just move on but when it
comes to actually doing queues or
similar stuff that i've rarely ever done
I was just proud to get a queue in here
that doesn't completely suck ass because
that's something that hasn't happened to
me too many times so I was actually
quite happy about that as as mediocre oh
well I suppose it's it's just eat it
it's not a great key
just decent at least that's what I what
I like to tell myself about it so in the
end of that sort of workouts and it's
always fun to just place flowers it'll
foliage things that's actually one of
the young I think one of the most fun
things to do in roller coaster three
though I I have brought this up in there
in the past I think but just because
it's a really simple mindless sort of
thing I mean planning a queue still does
take a tiny bit of your brain tiny bit
of that gray matter just to think about
how you need to plan it and how it even
works especially for me since I don't
really know too much about that um but
just flowers it's always just a fun
little thing to do if you ask me I
suppose it's the same sort of like
everything it's really hard to explain
it I would almost say like if you're
depressed they play roller coaster than
three or something I mean I would do
that if I were I think it's just that
that sort of thing that you can you can
just put all your bad thoughts or your
stress aside and just worry about
whether you want to have that little red
flower that little orange flower that's
that's really the appeal to me the
matter of that might actually have been
the best wording of my opinion about the
whole audio and that I've ever had and
the rest of this is honestly just trying
to get some little props to put it to
put next to it I didn't want to have
some those things are called cubby holes
right and i'm pretty sure that called
cubby holes where you just put your your
luggage in it's not like a chair you
just put your bags and whatever you
you'd be taken to a theme park pretty
sure that people take some surprising
[ __ ] to a theme park well in any case
you can you can put all your surprising
[ __ ] in the cubby holes and don't have
to worry about that on the ride neither
do i have to worry about guests looking
losing their [ __ ] on the ride so that's
good and then i just had to fill up the
roof over there yeah there really isn't
too much to the station I might go back
at it I might go back to it and just
kind of check out if there's anything I
want to change but then again I do feel
like that's the sort of thing where I
always say yeah I'll get back to that
later on and then just forget about it
and never get back to it and it's also
the sort of thing that in the end I feel
like I can just kind of say let's just
not film at too much let's not take
pictures of that
film it just uh just have it there so it
is there but not focus on it too much
that's the sort of thing also the train
track over here I was basically
hesitating to art to add anything on the
other side of the train track which is
why I'm not adding anything on the other
side of this frantic since I wanted to
get a train CT over there in the future
which should have more gentle slopes and
larger curves but the future videos
we'll have updates about that and how
it's going to go for now I'm almost
running out of time I am running out of
time so thank you for watching and I'll
see y'all guys wait a second let me redo
that I'll see you guys later hey